I talked yesterday, yesterday on the show
about this concept, stochastic terrorism.
Okay.
Stochastic terrorism once again is when through
media messages, through mass communication
methods, uh, if someone has a large enough
audience and they harp about the need to take
care of someone in the public eye or the need
to do something about a person or an organization,
it becomes statistically more and more likely
that someone in the audience will actually
be inspired to go and do something in the
real world as a result of those mass communication
messages that they've heard.
Glenn Beck famously was constantly ranting
and raving about the tides foundation with
all sorts of conspiracies and eventually it
actually inspired someone in his audience
to go and try to do something about the tides
foundation.
Hopefully, if I recall the story correctly,
he was stopped by a police on his way to do
that thing.
Now, of course, as as a current law, Glen
Beck cannot be found guilty in any way for
conspiring with that individual.
There is no actual connection.
It's through the mass messaging that that's
the castic terrorism is carried out.
This got us into the conversation of the impact
of the attacks that we've been seeing against
these four ethnic minority congresswoman called
the squad.
Uh, and what we have now seen is that the
Illinois Republican County Chairman's Association
shared a meme labeling them, not the squad,
but the Jihad squad.
And they apparently either realized it was
a terrible idea or deleted it after there
was a whole bunch of blow back after posting
it and they now are claiming, oh, that was
an unauthorized post to our social media accounts.
It does not represent our actual views.
The president of this Republican group is
Mark Shaw.
He said, quote, I condemn this unauthorized
posting and it has been deleted.
I am sorry if anyone who saw the image was
offended by the contents.
So this is problematic for a variety of reasons.
Number one, it again perpetuates the idea
that Muslims are terrorists and we've talked
before, I have no hesitation whatsoever to
point out that there are significant portions
of problematic beliefs among large numbers
of the world Muslim population, but perpetuating
this idea that merely by being Muslim there
is some terroristic link including by members
of the American Congress.
Unless you have really solid evidence of that,
you shouldn't say it, it's disgusting and
it's disastrous.
From a logistical standpoint, Alexandria Casio
Cortez is not Muslim.
I, Anna Presley is not Muslim as far as I
know.
Uh, so it doesn't even apply to two of the
four ethnic minority congresswoman that are
being referred to here.
And more importantly, it further xenophobia.
And again, when it goes back to the stochastic
terrorism element, it can cause people to
take real world action.
These members of congress now required beefed
up security.
Would any of you, if tomorrow I came to you
and said breaking news, there has been an
assassination attempt against one of those
four women.
Would any of you be surprised?
I don't think so.
I don't think you can say that.
That would be a surprising bit of news given
everything that's been going on and the media
rhetoric, the rhetoric in media from people
on the right about those four women and meanwhile
the Republicans won't pass the nine 11 victims
compensation fund.
Not exactly being tough on terror, right?
If you say, Hey, uh, we, we aren't even going
to pass this simple thing to actually deal
with taking care of the people that have been
victimized by actual radical Islamic ideology
rather than just for members of Congress that
we are slandering in this way.
And once again, the defenses are so pathetic.
Well, David, they didn't mean Jihad squad.
Literally it's symbolism.
We just disagree with them politically.
When they said send her home at Trump's North
Carolina rally, it wasn't literally sent her
home.
It was symbolically saying, we disagree respectfully
with your politics.
When the police officer said, Alexandria Cossio
Cortez deserves to be shot, the police chief
said it was inappropriate, but it's not a
literal threat from this cop.
This cop is not actually going to shoot her.
That cop has been suspended.
We learned in the last 24 hours, by the way,
and similarly the Jihad squad label.
Now they're saying, well, we're not literally
saying they are radical Muslim jihadists.
It's just symbolism for, we disagree with
their politics.
The cumulative effect here, I almost hesitate
to talk about it because I don't want it to
happen.
The cumulative effect is that someone may
well be pushed to do something in the real
world.
They used to pretend that the racists and
the Zener, both senior folks were just a small
portion.
They're not even pretending anymore.
It's actually campaign strategy.
I've said it last week and I'll repeat it.
Trump and pence are now actually running on
overtly xenophobic rhetoric sort of guised
as nationalism and even more innocuously patriotism.
We can see through it.
The people on the right, there's nothing for
them to see through.
They just like it and this may well get Donald
Trump reelected.
That's the sickest part of it all.
We are taking an audience poll related to
this issue on the David Pakman show Instagram
page.
Make sure you're following it at David Pakman
show.
And while you're there,
follow me at David Dot pacman on Instagram
as well.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this
on
a very, very busy moving deck